[Aplausos]
bueno buenas tardes a todos muchas
gracias por estar aquí muchas gracias
por la invitación yo también quiero
contar una historia y también está
relacionado con la ciencia pero les
tengo que comentar porque la ciencia
porque me motiva a mí la ciencia en
realidad
empezó desde que cuando empecé a
estudiar química en valparaíso en la
universidad en los últimos años de
estudiar química me di cuenta de que
estaba la bioquímica o sea también
estaba relacionado con la parte
biológica de algunos microorganismos que
habían muy pequeños y que lograban hacer
química en su forma en su en su mundo
pequeño me interesó tanto tanto que dije
me tengo que ir para afuera a seguir
estudiando a seguir y estudiando esta
bacteria el área de microbiología y por
eso me fui a alemania y ser doctorado lo
pasé muy bien conocí mucha gente muy
interesante y lo mejor de todo es que
pude aprender más del área de
microbiología en uno de los mejores
centros de poder estudiar estas
bacterias pero bueno eso no fue lo único
que yo quería más
y ahí se me ocurrió no quiero ir y me
fui a londres a otra universidad y ahí
hizo un posdoctorado por tres años
y notaria completamente distinto parece
que es como una marca registrada mía
porque estudia química y alemania y se
otra cosa nada que ver que no sabía pero
aprendí fui a la inglaterra era otra
área queda un poco atrás pijama pero
dije no aprendí así que puedo unir dos
pasiones el área de hacer ciencia en mi
área de microbiología que me gusta
muchísimo y realmente una pasión para mí
y también viajar por supuesto porque
pucha viajar por europa con otros estos
países fue realmente una belleza una
es genial y de verdad que no me
arrepiento en nada de haber hecho ese
ese cambio pero bueno después de todo
eso había que volver a chile
volver a chile no es tan fácil yo estuve
casi 10 años afuera
que voy a ser yo en chiles en sentido de
que por supuesto si estás haciendo
ciencia en estas universidades grandes
que tienen muchos recursos para realizar
lo que a ti se te da la gana
literalmente o sea por ejemplo si tienes
una idea loca de un experimento loco
basta solamente indagar un poquito en
esa misma universidad y te das cuenta
que tienes todo disponible o sea si a mí
se me ocurrió que yo creo que quería
crecer 60 bacterias distintas todas al
mismo tiempo procesar las
sistemáticamente y luego purificar 60
proteínas de estas 60 bacterias todo al
mismo tiempo
lo pude hacer había un robot entonces a
eso voy de los recursos que hay en el
exterior tu será fácil hacer ciencia
fuera si faltaba no más que tienen una
idea interesante si estos ellos pescaba
estas 60 proteínas
me los llevaba y empezaba a hacer
experimentos con ella
volver a chile
no volver a chile difícil pero no
imposible
entonces ese era mi gran desafío en
realidad porque uno aprende mucho afuera
tienes todos los recursos se los
mencioné y como lo hago en chile como
puedo hacer yo una científica reconocía
en chile
y ese era el gran desafío que yo venía
como hacer un link de hacer ciencia
biología en un área que no se conoce
tanto acá
pero no me mal interpreten porque aquí
en chile tenemos muy buenos
microbiólogos a lo largo de chile en el
norte en el sur aquí en santiago en las
regiones es realmente impresionante lo
que pueden hacer yo quería ser como algo
un poco distinto y tratar de hacerme
camino porque estando fuera tanto tiempo
no es fácil si entonces ya saben las dos
pasiones que me tengo cierto la
microbiología y viajar yo quería unir
las dos
y por supuesto yo seguía pensando qué
voy a hacer acá mientras vivía aquí en
chile es lo que empecé a viajar
empecé a viajar a lo largo de chile por
supuesto uno después que viene de afuera
quiere conocer más su país y ahí podemos
ver lo impresionante que es todos los
países que tenemos en chile y ahí
podemos ver desde el norte con un
desierto árido sí hasta el sur que es
donde podemos ver todos los hielos del
sol si la patagonia o el desierto
florido que ahora me han dicho que está
muy lindo
tenemos una diversidad de ecosistemas
inimaginables en el cual nosotros el
microbiólogo podemos explorar
me encanta chile sí es muy lindo
pero bueno que en que me base yo en qué
etapa empecé iba a trabajar
en el mar tan largo que tenemos otro
tenemos una costa gigante en chile que
realmente es enorme y todo mirando hacia
el océano pacífico que es por supuesto
el océano más grande del mundo sí y por
qué me gusta tanto entre él y yo miro
esta foto que una foto que saqué yo del
mar a mí me dan ganas de meterme en esa
ola que se ve ahí sí me gusta estar ahí
en contacto con el agua me gusta estar
ahí mirando la tranquilidad que me da o
también ver lo dinámico que es también
me gusta comer los mariscos que proveen
nuestro mar sí entonces le tengo mucho
cariño al mar y bueno y tengo suerte que
vivo en viña y valparaíso trabajo en
valparaíso entonces puedo ver siempre el
mar
y ahí empezó el bichito indigente y si
vamos buscando bacterias que vienen del
mar porque si tenemos bakker en todas
partes sí y en el mar también y ahí está
la cosa dije así si empiezo a muestrear
distintas partes de chile distintas
costas chilenas perfecto
hacemos las dos pasiones en una
empezamos por supuesto generando
trabajando mucho para encontrar
proyectos que son gubernamentales que
logre ganar y ahí empecé con un poco de
plata armar todo un poco más el
laboratorio y también hacer muestreos en
distintas partes del mar
entonces vamos a bucear perfecto vamos a
bucear excelente me encanta la idea hay
un detalle yo no sé bucear sí pero bueno
contratamos así que seguimos adelante
pero hay otro detalle más
si tú me pones en un bote y el bote se
empieza a mover tú me mareo
es terrible de hecho en los muestreos me
tienen que dejar en una isla pequeña los
chicos muestran hacían las cosas y yo
mirando sacando fotos de una isla
pequeña pequeña de una roca básicamente
y después me metí al un bote para volver
sí
y que muestre amos a dónde puedo
encontrar estas bacterias maravillosas
que les muestro que les comento yo una
son de estas monjas marinas y
precisamente esa esponja marina
estuvimos muestreando nosotros también
recolectamos segmentos marinos y esos
son las muestras que empezamos nosotros
a trabajar y aquí por supuesto les tengo
comentar este trabajo es en equipo no
soy yo solamente haciendo eso con
estudiantes con asistente científico
todos aportando para tratar de procesar
las muestras lo más rápido posible para
encontrar nuestras bacterias así y ahí
ustedes pueden ver in situ ahí es
como dice general de aceituno en la
caleta en general de aceituno que
llevamos todo un armamento para ir a
trabajar ahí mismo
lo que les quiero mostrar es los
distintos lugares que hemos logrado
muestrear en el sur tenemos un fiordo
que es de la patagonia del norte
arriba tenemos general de aceituno por
supuesto que nuestra casa valparaíso
tiene que estar ahí y va que más isla de
pascua también sí así que hemos podido
viajar y hacer ciencia
y bueno estos son nuestros protagonistas
se las tenía que mostrar tanto que no y
esas son algunas de las bacterias que
hemos sido capaces de aislar de estas
esponjas marinas y desde los sedimentos
marinos que hemos recolectado a lo largo
de chile sí ahora son muy lindas la
verdad los colores las texturas y todas
esas cosas pero bueno todo es muy bonito
así y qué hacemos con ellas
qué podemos hacer con ellas
podemos responder algún algún problema o
crisis mundial con ellos seremos capaces
de hacer algo así
ustedes
han tenido por ejemplo un problema a la
garganta que le empieza a doler
les pica y después se dan cuenta van al
doctor dice en cuenta que fue producido
por una bacteria o tienen un hijo un
hijo que es con un dolores de oído fatal
si van al doctor y de nuevo
es una bacteria que la está produciendo
bueno por supuesto que tenemos
tratamientos son los antibióticos y
todos sabemos que tenemos antibióticos
para tratar ciertas enfermedades pero
estamos con problemas porque porque en
realidad lo que está sucediendo ahora es
que esas bacterias que producen esas
enfermedades se están transformando y
están creando generando resistencia a
los antibióticos que usamos hoy en día
y un problema bastante grande
entonces como le estaba comentando yo
esa bacteria que nos producen enfermedad
a nosotros
si le estamos dando antibióticos pero
parece que se empiezan a generar
resistencia y crear que hace más fuerte
contra los antibióticos de hoy en día y
eso es lo que quería visualizar acá
y el tratamiento en la prensa de hecho
en una en un diario de canarias que está
ahí en el último año han generado harta
publicidad con respecto a este problema
que una crisis mundial en el fondo y por
ejemplo aquí la organización mundial de
salud comenta que hay muy pocos
antibióticos que están siendo estudiados
en la última etapa de los ensayos
clínicos para que puedan ser
antibióticos no no tenemos suficiente ha
sido un poco difícil generar nuevos
antibióticos y también incluso la jefa
médica de inglaterra es una mujer
también habla de este problema de hecho
ya empieza a hablar de apocalipsis de
antibióticos no tenemos suficiente
antibiótico
también otro experto que empiezan a
hablar que nuestros nuestros
antibióticos de última generación no
están funcionando de lo mejor pero bueno
aquí estoy montando todas las cosas como
malas pero también hay otros científicos
están generando nuevos medicamentos para
pues llevar a cabo y tratar de resolver
este problema mundial sí
y eso es en realidad lo que estamos
haciendo nosotros desde aquí chelito con
nuestra biodiversidad tan enorme y
grande logramos encontrar bacterias
nuevas bacterias porque a lo mejor esas
nuevas bacterias para estar generando
produciendo esos nuevos antibióticos que
necesitamos aquí en el mundo
quién sabe a lo mejor nosotros vamos a
tener el próximo antibiótico que va a
salir en el en el comercio muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]